welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Deadpool just poked his head
through a Time door into the MCU and
said it gets me every time Deadpool 3
co-starring Wolverine is still on the
horizon and since Deadpool 2 ended with
Wade using Cable's time travel watch to
slide through time it's more or less
guaranteed that the MCU multiversal time
travel mechanics will be the rationale
behind Deadpool's arrival into it which
made it especially interesting to see a
flirty exchange between Ryan Reynolds
and a known Miss minutes account on
Twitter while easy to shrug this off as
a bit of harmless banter on a rapidly
sinking ship of a social media platform
there are a few interesting wrinkles to
this that make it worth looking deeper
into so let's break this down with a
classic new rock stars tweet down
okay it all started on Monday November
28th at 9 21 a.m Pacific time when
Twitter account at Miss minutes TVA
tweeted hey there Deadpool weave Emoji
love Miss minutes orange heart clock
emoji and seven hours after this at 5 pm
on the dot Brian Reynolds replied from
his personal account hello Miss Bennetts
and what's interesting is Reynolds
didn't tweet from the Deadpool account
that Ms minutes initially tagged he saw
this Miss minutes tweet independently
and responded to it from his personal
account now this mitzving its account
has a sizeable following but as far as
we can tell it's not necessarily an
official Marvel Studios account like
it's not verified though these days
Twitter verification doesn't really mean
anything in fact when I see someone I've
never heard of with that blue check mark
I think oh bless your heart you have
eight dollars in an inferiority complex
but there are some reasons to think this
account has some Merit it is followed by
Michael Waldron the Loki series Creator
the screenwriter of Multiverse of
Madness and Avengers Secret Wars really
the Mind arguably most directly
influencing the ground level direction
of the Multiverse Saga at the moment
Aldrin more than anyone else is the
brainchild of minutes character a
character that did not exist in Marvel
Comics before the Loki series and the
character important enough to Marvel
Studios head Kevin feige that he wore
her on his ball cap when he first
introduced his Phase 5 and Phase 6 plans
at San Diego Comic-Con last summer and a
few weeks ago this same missed minutes
count on Twitter cryptically tweeted
some binary code that translated to just
checking in a tweet that I responded to
and translated but since then that
original tweet was mysteriously deleted
now tweets get deleted all the time for
all kinds of reasons but if this is a
fan account just for fun just trying to
engage big names from the Marvel World
why delete anything what would it have
to lose what pressure would it be under
from Marvel Studios the way Disney and
Marvel Studios have been known to do
with their own cast and crew I'm just
saying it's very possible that this
account is run by someone working on
these titles okay you know what I've
been talking way too much I need a
little water break
oh uh you wanna know a Trixie little
secret I am drinking regular water here
but it tastes like orange vanilla and
that's because this ain't no regular
water bottle this is an air uh I'm
drinking water what kind of water is it
it's era air up is an easy way to make
staying hydrated less boring it adds
flavor to your water with scent alone so
you can get all the water you need and
all the flavor you want it's really easy
you just take one of these flavor pods
you pop it onto one of these bottles and
then you take a drink
it's crazy but also if you ever want
just plain water all you got to do is
push the Pod down where did that flavor
water now it's
it's air up makes a great gift and right
now there are a ton of discounted
holiday bundles on air Up's website that
make perfect stocking stuffers for
everybody on your list because honestly
everybody needs water and if you're
looking for some flavored variety the
naughty list bundle has a green air up
bottle it comes with orange vanilla and
raspberry lemon and mango passion fruit
flavor pod packs raspberry lemons might
go to when it's hot out and I want
something refreshing but during the
winter if I'm chilly I go for the orange
vanilla all day every day there are
other holiday bundles available as well
including Berry all the way dashing Duo
and B cherry and bright and if you go
now you can take advantage of air Up's
holiday special and get a bundle for
yourself or whoever you buy gifts for
for 20 to 25 off each holiday bundle has
everything you need to start up your air
up Journey but they'll only be available
until December 26th click the link in
the description below to get started now
later miss minutes quote tweeted Ryan
Reynolds response with a blush emoji
hand over the mouth with the eyes closed
Emoji which we should point out it's not
the yawn Emoji it's more of a gasp emoji
and then an orchard with a clock and
prior to Reynolds response when someone
asked if they were saying that Miss
minutes would appear in Deadpool 3 this
account responded nah just saying hi to
the neighborhood Merc with Mal and again
if this is a jokey fan account why speak
with any Authority at all on whether or
not miss Municipal cameo in any Marvel
title if it is just a phony account run
by some nobody this person wouldn't know
whether or not Misfit it's gonna appear
in anything really I just think this
response was the account's way of saying
my tweet to Deadpool wasn't meant to
confirm anything either way we're just
having fun here and to that I would
agree but what's more interesting to me
is that Brian Reynolds actually
responded from his personal account that
wasn't even tagged in the initial
exchange I highly recommend you all go
back to rewatch Deadpool 2 because the
time travel logic presented in that film
does fit in neatly with the way time
travel is being depicted in the MCU
through the Loki series and Kang's
temporal technology not only does the
time travel technology in Deadpool 2
radiate the same orange glow that the
TVA Tech does with its time doors and
with Miss minutes Cable's device is
based on the cogs and gears of a
wristwatch an old school representation
of time just like Miss minutes clock
face is now Deadpool 2's Narrative
Approach to time travel logic is a bit
more loose and joke driven it is a
device to slide through time the longer
I travel the harder it is to control I
got two charges one to get me here one
to get me home
that's just lazy writing there doesn't
really seem to be a fixed sacred
timeline in the universe of Deadpool and
cable like cable travels back in time to
kill Russell Collins before we can grow
up to torch his wife and daughter
essentially to change the timeline and
the Final Act cable uses his second
charge to go back to before Deadpool's
self-sacrifice that Deadpool did to
prevent Russell's evil turn and this
time cable slips Deadpool's arcade token
to block the bullet and save Deadpool's
life and in the credits Montage
negasonic teenage Warhead and Yukio fix
the device and Temple uses it to save
Vanessa and some of the members of the
X-Force and to change his cameo in X-Men
origins of Wolverine to kill Ryan
Reynolds before shooting Green Lantern
and to kill Baby Hitler and all of these
changes seem to contradict Loki's
approach to time travel that branches
from the sacred timeline end up getting
pruned by the TBA however we do not know
if any of Deadpool's changes actually
stuck one could argue that everything he
did made him more of a criminal in the
eyes of the TVA the TVA could undo
everything we saw Deadpool do in that
movie with just a few reset charges and
again that's either our TVA if there is
just one TVA that oversees the full
Multiverse or if there are an infinite
tdas whatever the TBA was that oversaw
Deadpool's Universe now yes new Rockstar
says theorized this in a past episode of
Rogue Theory which Mt had the perfect
timing to respond to miss minutes and
Ryan Reynolds with but there's also some
strong parallels with how Deadpool 2
describe the time travel Tech as charges
aligning with the reset charges used by
the TVA to prune timelines and the way
Deadpool described what he was doing
when he met Wolverine hey it's me down
scratch
just cleaning up the timelines cleaning
up the timelines essentially the tva's
core Mission some of the TVA would be
pretty pissed off if someone else tried
to do so it's not that hard to conceive
how this could actually work in Phase 5
of the MCU Cable's time travel Tech
could really be an early prototype of
the temporal Tech that Nathaniel
Richards will eventually engineer or
possibly a piece of tech that a Kang
variant in a path Multiverse award lost
track of that cable was able to recover
in the past I've speculated that Kang
would have wanted to kill Tony Stark
Iron Man precisely after the moment Tony
discovered time travel with his inverted
Mobius strip simulation the significance
of that moment inspiring he remains to
name one of his Cronin monitors movies
and Mobius because that moment would
have been the first link in the chain
through history that would have resulted
in Nathaniel Richards becoming a master
of time a thousand years later and maybe
cable is the missing link in between
Tony Stark and Nathaniel Richards
someone who would take Tony Stark's
Theory and apply it to technology
without having to go through the quantum
realm and Kang could later build on
cables technology to Lord over the
Multiverse and disseminate his time
travel technology and to a full
bureaucratic agency to do it for him so
could Ms minutes be a time travel
companion to Deadpool and Wolverine and
cable in Deadpool 3 maybe maybe not but
Reynold's response to this makes it at
least likelier that this guy could make
a cameo as a prisoner in the TVA in Loki
season 2 like a prisoner in the
background as we saw that one Peggy
Carter look alike being pushed around in
the background of Loki episode one or
maybe even Wade Wilson's voice shouting
from the other side of a door in the TDA
solitary confinement because really
Deadpool's starting as an inmate
awaiting trial of the TVA really makes
the most sense for his MCU origin it
would both adopt everything the
character went through in his past Fox
films but also forced the character to
join the MCU by first being processed at
this frustrating meta Nexus weigh
station giving Deadpool first some
annoying red tape to have to fight
through before he gains the rights to
join the other Marvel heroes in the MCU
let me know your thoughts on all this in
the comments below and hey if you happen
to be in the Los Angeles area this
weekend come see me and the rest of the
new rock stars host live at La Comic Con
Sunday December 4th at 10 30 a.m we'd
love to hang out with you you can follow
me on Tick Tock Hive Instagram and
Twitter at eat a boss follow me Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]